La era de Barack Obama, uno de los
presidentes sin duda más
mediáticos y populares de la historia
de los Estados Unidos ha llegado a su
fin.
Si tuviésemos que definir a Obama bien
podríamos decir que ha sido una
brillante estrella a cuyo lado muchos de
los grandes nombres de Hollywood
quedarían eclipsados.
Obama, amigos
de VisualPolitik no sólo gano la
Casa Blanca sino que con la promesa de
contribuir a construir un mundo mejor y
a regenerar la forma de hacer política se
hizo con las esperanzas cientos de
millones de personas, dentro y fuera de
los Estados Unidos. Como es normal con el
paso de los años su brillo ha perdido
fuerza y la controversia, se puede decir,
ganó a la percepción casi mesiánica
con la que llegó al poder.
Porque, amigos, Obama más que un
presidente parecía el salvador de la
humanidad. Pues bien, si en un vídeo
anterior
repasamos su política internacional,
en este vídeo queremos fijarnos en la
herencia que le deja a su sucesor en el
Despacho Oval, Donald Tramp.
Si algo está claro es que Barack
Obama llegó al poder en uno de los
momentos más difíciles que un
político se puede imaginar, en medio de
una época que parecía incluso el
propio Armagedón.
En aquel entonces, a finales de 2008 y
principios de 2009, cada mes 800 mil
estadounidenses perdían su trabajo;
las bolsas se desplomaban; el sistema
financiero parecía fuera de control, en
caída libre; y los periódicos
prácticamente habría cada día con
la quiebra de algún gran grupo
empresarial. Hoy, ocho años después, las
cosas son bastante distintas y obama es,
por supuesto, el primero en recordarlo.
- "La verdad es que si tuvieras que elegir
un momento de la historia para estar
vivo escogerías esté, aquí mismo, en
América.
Ahora mismo, se mida como se mida, este
país es mejor y el mundo es mejor de lo
que lo era hace 50, 30 u 8 años".
Sin embargo, esta es una imagen que puede
sorprendernos si tenemos en cuenta que
cuando se le pregunta a los ciudadanos
de Estados Unidos si su país está mejor
o peor que hace diez años, los
estadounidenses parecen confusos,
indecisos, y una gran mayoría de ellos,
más de dos terceras partes, afirman que
el país sigue un rumbo equivocado.
Una postura, claro, que resulta menos
extraña si tenemos en cuenta el
caldo de cultivo generado durante la
última campaña por algunos medios de
comunicación y especialmente algunos
políticos. Es el caso, desde luego, de
Donald Trump cuyo discurso político
describía Estados Unidos como un país
en crisis, decadente y casi como un
estado fallido, del que llegó a decir
que se estaba convirtiendo, ni más ni
menos, que en un país del tercer mundo.
Tal y como dijo en el Washington Post:
- "Creo que éramos un país muy poderoso,
muy rico y ahora somos un país pobre".
No sé si del tercer mundo, pero una cosa es
cierta.
Cuando visitas Estados Unidos te
das cuenta que las infraestructuras, las
carreteras del país están que se caen
a pedazos. Bien, llegados a este punto la
pregunta es clara: ¿quién de los dos
tiene razón? o al menos ¿quién se
aproxima más a la verdad? Pues bien, para
contestar a esta pregunta
vamos a tratar de hacer una fotografía
de la herencia que deja Barack Obama, de
los principales indicadores económicos
de Estados Unidos.
Nunca antes en la historia de Estados
Unidos había habido tantos empleos como
hoy en día. Algo más de 152 millones de
personas trabajan en la economía
norteamericana.
De tal forma que, durante la presidencia
de Barack Obama, se han creado más de 11
millones de nuevos puestos de trabajo en
el sector privado,
15 si contamos desde que comenzó la
recuperación. Ojo, porque son muchos
empleos.
Por ejemplo, en el mismo periodo de
tiempo la eurozona ha destruido empleo,
de tal forma que aún hoy la zona euro
tienen menos trabajadores que en 2008.
Aquí podéis ver la diferente
evolución de ambos territorios.
Hoy la tasa de desempleo en Estados Unidos
está, atentos, en torno al 4,5 por ciento. No está mal.
Y no se trata sólo de la
cifra bruta de empleo, en términos
reales
los ingresos medios por trabajador se
encuentran ya en máximos históricos y
desde 2012 los salarios han aumentado más
de un 5 por ciento en términos reales,
es decir una vez descontada ya la
inflación.
Los estadounidenses tienen hoy más
trabajo y de media mejores salarios que
nunca antes en la historia
Esto sí que parece una recuperación, lo
mismo deberían tomar nota en España.
Y, claro, como resultado de todo este
proceso, el porcentaje de estadounidenses
considerados como pobres cayó a su
nivel mínimo en ocho años,
y, ojo, la reducción de la pobreza
relativa ha sido generalizada, se ha
producido en todos los estados y en
todos los grupos de edad.
- "Cuando Obama llegó a la casa blanca en 2009 la tasa
de pobreza era del 14,5 por ciento. El
dato más reciente de la oficina del
censo americano muestra que la cifra se
ha reducido hasta el 13,7 por ciento el
año pasado".
Desde sus niveles más bajos como
consecuencia de la crisis, los precios de
la vivienda ya están repuntando y el
SP-500, el índice que mide la actividad
de los mercados de valores de Estados
Unidos
también hoy se encuentra en máximos
históricos. Todo esto ha hecho que el
patrimonio de las familias, su riqueza, se
haya disparado bajo la presidencia de
Obama más de un 20 por ciento limpio de
inflación. Hay quien incluso ya dice que
estamos a las puertas de una nueva
época de años locos.
- "La asociación de agentes de bienes
raíces indicó que el inventario subió
en julio un 5,6 por ciento y llegó a 2
millones 280 mil casas a la venta".
Y más: la producción industrial se ha
recuperado y está casi en máximos
históricos; el país es menos
dependiente del petróleo extranjero de
lo que lo ha sido en las tres últimas
décadas; las exportaciones crecen con
fuerza y los beneficios empresariales se
han más que doblado.
- "Hace 40 años el mercado productor de petróleo era
liderado por países como Arabia Saudita
y Rusia
hoy la historia ha cambiado gracias a la
tecnología y Estados Unidos ocupa ese lugar".
Más empleos, más salarios, más
riqueza,
Barack Obama tomó un barco que hacía
aguas y hoy, ocho años después, deja
como legado una sólida recuperación
que ha llevado a la economía
estadounidense a cifras récord. De hecho, su
PIB real cierra 2016 en un nivel un 12
por ciento superior al máximo alcanzado
antes de
crisis. Hoy la economía estadounidense
es más grande que nunca.
No es extraño que bajo este escenario
la Reserva Federal comienza a poner
orden en su política monetaria y haya
comenzado ya a subir los tipos de
interés.
- "Nuestras proyecciones elevan los tipos
de interés al 1,4 por ciento para
finales del año que viene al 2,1 por
ciento para finales de 2018 y al 2,9 por
ciento para finales de 2019".
Y si las cosas se siguen haciendo bien,
Estados Unidos tiene un futuro
prometedor.
Por cierto, para todos los que tengan la
tentación de creer que Obama ha
expandido al gasto público, siento
defraudaros porque lo cierto es que en
términos del PIB lo ha reducido
sustancialmente. Algo muy distinto a lo
que como veis ha hecho por ejemplo
España.
Ahora bien, no todo son luces. Los
críticos de Obama ponen sobre la mesa
sombras que también nosotros
compartimos.
Con seguridad la mayor crítica que
recibe Obama ha sido la referente a su
incapacidad para controlar las cuentas
públicas. Es verdad que desde 2009 el
déficit público se ha reducido
sustancialmente, en dos terceras partes,
pero también lo es que continúa siendo
bastante abultado, y que incluso la
previsión es que empeore en los
próximos años si no se llevan a cabo
importantes recortes del gasto.
- "Nuestra proyección, asumiendo una
continuación en las políticas, es que
el déficit supere el billón de
dólares en 2020, ligeramente por debajo
del 5% del PIB".
Esta pobre estimación puede que explique por qué Obama apenas
se refiere al presupuesto federal o a la
deuda pública cuando recalca sus logros.
Y es que, atentos a esta realidad porque
es impresionante,
durante los ocho años de presidencia de
Obama el déficit acumulado del gobierno
federal ha sido de 7,3 billones de
dólares.
Ojo a este dato porque implica que en
tan sólo los dos mandatos de Obama,
la deuda pública ha aumentado en un
importe que es más del doble que toda
la deuda acumulada desde la
independencia del país. Es decir, Obama
se ha endeudado  más que todos los
presidentes de la historia de Estados
Unidos
¡juntos!
Impresionante. O por ejemplo, otra forma
de verlo,
este incremento de la deuda equivale a
todo el gasto militar de Rusia durante
los próximos 100 años.
Claro, esto nos parece muchísimo, pero no
podemos olvidar que en España hemos
consumido más recursos relativos y hoy
tenemos más déficit, más deuda, menos
trabajo, y menos salarios que antes de la
crisis.
Así que, algo bien habrá hecho Obama.
- " Sí, me voy a votar a sí mismo porque confío
en mí".
De todas formas no son pocos los
economistas que critican que con todos
los estímulos aplicados, tanto por los
diferentes gobiernos como por la Reserva
Federal, y además en el marco de una
política de tipos cero, la recuperación
no ha sido tan vigorosa. Los partidarios
de Obama responden que esto se debe,
fundamentalmente, a que es muy difícil
estimar la producción de la nueva
industria digital y a que la demografía
está envejeciendo. Por otra parte, a pesar
de las cifras récord de empleo, son
muchos los que apuntan que la creación
de empleo no está siendo lo
suficientemente fuerte como para hacer
frente a toda la demanda potencial
existente, lo que achacan a las numerosas
regulaciones introducidas por el
presidente.
De hecho, tanto el Índice Doing Business
como en el Índice de Libertad
Económica, Estados Unidos ha perdido
varios puestos desde la llegada al poder de Obama
- "El presidente de Estados Unidos,
Barack Obama, ordena al Departamento de
Trabajo que impulse nuevas normas para
evitar conflictos de intereses entre las
corredurías de Wall Street que asesoran a
clientes sobre sus inversiones
vinculadas a pensiones".
Y la última crítica: a pesar de la buena marcha de
las cosas, aún hay 43 millones de
personas consideradas pobres en Estados
Unidos, y desde luego eso desafina la
interpretación del primer presidente
afroamericano de la historia de este
país.
En fin, por la economía y por las
reformas que ha implantado más allá de ella,
como veíamos en política exterior,
personalmente creo que la valoración
que se pueda hacer de Obama es
bastante positiva y, a pesar de las
sombras que hay, nadie puede tener
ninguna duda:
Estados Unidos es un país mejor hoy que
hace 50, 30 e incluso 8 años.
Bueno, ¿tú qué opinas sobre Obama? ¿Te ha
parecido un buen Presidente
o eres de los que creen que ha
incumplido las expectativas? Fácil desde
luego no lo ha tenido.
Espero que te haya gustado este vídeo,
si ha sido así no dudes en darle
a like y suscribirte al canal si aún
no lo has hecho. Lo puedes hacer ahora,
gratis,
pulsando en este botón. Un saludo y hasta
la próxima amigos.